Und dazu gibt es eine Vorgeschichte, dass ich sozusagen, also weil Refugee... Ich brüchte bitte. Papa Geif, meiner Schulter, der sagen, was man für mich sagt. Refugee Emancipation hat ja in den sozusagen, also funktioniert vor allem in der Heimat. Dann gibt es sozusagen die Hacker-Community, davon auch Teil Freifunker und so weiter. Wie ist das zusammengekommen?
Ja, also im Prinzip waren die Freifunker also nun schon dabei, Flüchtlingsheime und Unterkünfte zu vernetzen. Und eines Tages, wir machen da regelmäßige Treffen in der Sea-Base in Berlin, immer Mittwochs um 20 Uhr. Und eines Tages saß da Philipp und hat erzählt, er hat da Leute vom Refugees Emancipation Projekt getroffen. Und das sei also ganz spannend. Und die würden auch gern in den Heimen WLAN anbieten, weil die Kapazität von so einem Internetcafé natürlich auch begrenzt ist oder die Anzahl der Sitzplätze, man das ein bisschen ausbauen möchte. Und wie wir da denn nun zusammenkommen könnten. Ja, und dann haben wir gesagt, na klar, machen wir das. Und weil ich aber parallel davon gehört habe, dass der Club zu der Zeit Laptops gesammelt hat, sind wir dann als nächstes Chaos Computer Club Berlin aufgeschlagen und haben mit den Leuten unterhalten über das Thema Hardware-Spenden und so weiter. Und die erste Aktion war dann eigentlich, die Hardware-Spenden zu sammeln.
Ja, fast die Hardware-Spenden.
Ich muss mal sehr schnell kurz unterbrechen. Ich habe nämlich, weil wir gerade auch von Fails reden, noch was vergessen vorzustellen an dieser Stelle. Was soll man sagen? Das war gerade Monique Meisel von den Freifunkern. Jetzt Lasse vom Chaos Computer Club, der nochmal genauer erzählt, wie das war.
Das Sammeln der Laptops war das netzpolitische Forum der SPD, die das gemacht haben, die damals den Chaos Computer Club gefragt haben, ob wir sie dabei unterstützen würden, was wir abgelehnt haben, da wir als Chaos Computer Club generell nicht mit Parteien arbeiten. Nach der Ablehnung bin ich hintenrum dann zu ihnen wieder hingerannt und habe gesagt, na gut, wenn ihr die sammelt, dann helfe ich euch beim Einrichten. Und da stellte sich dann, nachdem wir die eingerichtet hatten, halt raus, dass die gar keine Idee hatten, an wen diese 20 Laptops, 30 Laptops jetzt gehen sollen. Wir haben dann mal geguckt, 60 Flüchtlingsunterkünfte in Berlin, 13.000 Flüchtlinge bevor. Wir reden jetzt von Ende letzten Jahres. Also andere Situationen auch hier in Deutschland. Genau November war's. Und in der Fragestellung sozusagen, wem geben wir die denn jetzt? Da hat Monique sich bei mir mal gemeldet und mir von Refugee Emancipation erzählt, was wir sofort super spannend fanden, weil wir in dem Moment es eben nicht an einzelne Flüchtlinge in Privatbesitz geben, sondern an einen Verein, der es wieder vielen zur Verfügung stellt. Und die SPD, dieses Forum war auch sehr offen dafür, dass wir das an Refugee Emancipation geben dürfen, die Laptops. Und so kam man dann eigentlich zusammen. Wir haben damals die Aktion als Einzelperson dann beendet. Und Monique und ich sagten aber, das reicht uns jetzt nicht. Wir möchten Refugee Emancipation gerne noch mehr und weiter unterstützen, als ihnen jetzt einmal 20 Laptops zu geben. Und im Gespräch mit immer und eben kam dann halt immer wieder der Punkt, bei all den Sachen, die sie gerne noch machen würden und wo es drückt und was fehlt, Geld. Das war verschiedenste Themen, aber ganz oft lief es darauf hinaus, um das zu realisieren, braucht man Geld. Sei es jetzt eben, um die Internetadministratoren auf einen Workshop zu schicken, dass die alle mal bei uns im Berliner Club vorbeikommen, das ist einfach für die eine teure Reise. Das haben wir nicht so im Blick, aber Flüchtlinge, selbst wenn du sagst, da sind doch nur 15 Euro, dann können sie mit dem und dem Ticket fahren, das kostet halt alles wieder Geld, die geben eh schon ihre Freizeit und sollen dann noch Geld dafür bezahlen von dem wenigen, was sie haben. Und so kam bei uns eigentlich der Moment, wo wir gesagt haben, okay, dann besorgen wir euch jetzt Geld und planen eine Spendenkampagne zugunsten von Refugee Emancipation. Und mussten dann aber erstmal feststellen, dass wir zu zweit das auch nicht so ganz hinkriegen, weil man weiß ja, wie so eine Kampagne aussehen soll. Man hat da ja ein Bild von und mit Video und was man sich da nicht alles schön ausmalt. Und dann haben wir festgestellt, da sind wir aber ein bisschen weniger für, um das alles zu realisieren.
Aber bevor wir dazu kommen, wie das weiterging, könnte ich noch mal ein bisschen genauer erlauberieren, wofür das Geld gebraucht wird, also was da genau passiert. Außer sozusagen Fahrtkosten für die Internetadministratoren.
Also wie ich dann schon mal gesagt habe, wir wollen zuerst mal ein bisschen Stabilität in den Internetcafés haben. Dann wollen wir die Verantwortlichen für die Internetcafés ein bisschen Geld anbieten, für diese tolle Leistung, die sie dann dort machen. Und dann haben wir immer Computerkursen, Flüchtlingsheime in Internetcafés. Und es gibt Flüchtlinge, die außerhalb kommen. Wenn wir zum Beispiel im Potsdamer Computerkurs, drei Monate Computerkurs anbieten, dann wollen die Flüchtlinge, die in Telto wohnen, die in Brandenburg an der Havel und andere Plätze in Brandenburg, wollen sie auch teilnehmen. Aber das fehlt dann, das Geld für die Fahrkosten. Und wenn wir die Möglichkeit hätten, diese Flüchtlinge Fahrkosten dann zu zahlen, dass sie auch teilnehmen könnten, das wäre toll. Deswegen brauchen wir Geld für Fahrkosten, für diese Cuse, die wir im Internetcafe anbieten. Und dann brauchen wir auch Fahrkosten für die Techniker. Also wir haben immer Computers, die kaputt gehen oder da fehlt ein Maus oder so weiter. Und wir haben so Techniker, die von Internetcafe zu Internetcafe gehen und diese Technik dann zu reparieren. Dann brauchen wir zumindest Fahrkosten. Manchmal auch ein bisschen Honorar für diese Techniker. Und dann, ja, also Fahrkosten sind sehr wichtige Punkte, wofür wir das Geld brauchen. Und dann wir haben auch Büromiete. Dann haben wir auch Leute, die im Büro helfen, die bis jetzt gar nicht bekommen haben. Also wir wollen einfach mal Geld für alle diese Sachen dann.
Die Internetanschlüsse kosten. Es fehlt dann Werkzeug, damit eben, wie immer schön beschrieben hat gerade, die haben ihre eigenen Techniker, die rumreisen, das auf eigene Kosten tun. Aber die brauchen dann auch das entsprechende Werkzeug dazu. Was auch schön zu unserem Titel, so ein bisschen fast Flüchtlinge und Hacker, haben wir es genannt. Es gibt natürlich einen Haufen Flüchtlinge, die Hacker sind. Ich weiß nicht, ob man Jacob Applebaum als Flüchtling bezeichnen würde, aber ich glaube, der möchte gerade auch nicht zurück in sein Land. Und so ein paar andere fallen mir da auch ein, die halt aus der sogenannten ersten Welt kommen, die nehmen halt ein Flugzeug. Viele andere können halt kein Flugzeug hierher nehmen und kommen hier erst mal nicht rein. Aber geflüchtet sind diese Menschen auch. Da fragen wir auch nicht einen Jacob Applebaum, warum er Internet will nebenbei.
Das stimmt. Aber ich höre das jetzt sogar, das sind alles Einzelposten, die jetzt im Einzelnen irgendwie für uns als reiche Erstwälder nicht so dramatisch klingen, aber die sozusagen so zusammen dann schon ein größeres Paket sind.
Wir können ja mal über so ein Reden, also die Refugee Emancipation hat letztes Jahr eine Spendenkampagne probiert durchzuführen und vorbereitet. Und da sind von 6000 Euro, die sie sich gewünscht haben für ein Jahr, ich glaube es waren 50 Euro zusammen bekommen.
Und das war dann genau auch der Grund, warum wir gesagt haben, da können wir vielleicht ein bisschen unter die Arme greifen, eine Kampagne etwas professioneller mit unseren Erfahrungen zu unterstützen, unsere Kontakte zu nutzen. Richtig und einfach auch noch weitere Organisationen jetzt im nächsten Schritt dahinter zu versammeln, die einfach dort unterstützen auf den verschiedensten Ebenen. Aber im ersten Schritt geht es tatsächlich um Geld. Und diese 6000 Euro am Anfang waren ja recht bescheiden, da ging es dann auch nicht um ein ganzes Jahr, da ging es dann nur mal drei Monate Fahrradkosten für einen Lehrer. Wenn wir das jetzt alles überschlagen, kommen wir da auf deutliche Summen. Das Ziel wäre schon, mit einer recht großen Summe dieses Projekt für mindestens ein Jahr im Voraus entsprechend auszustatten, die sowohl die bestehenden Heime, also die Internetcafés in den Heimen, weiter betreiben zu können, als auch, eben hatte gesagt, zwei neue pro Jahr wären realistisch eben auch auszustatten. Wenn man diese ganzen Fahrtkosten mal überschlägt, dann sammelt sich das da ganz schön. Also da kommen wirklich Summen zusammen, da reden wir von mehreren Zehntausend Euro.
Und es geht ein Stück weit aus meiner Sicht zumindest auch um Vertrauen. Refugee Emancipation hat jetzt wirklich in 14 Jahren unbeobachtet von allen und an allen vorbei mal eben acht Internetcafés in Flüchtlingsunterkünften bereitgestellt aus eigener Tasche sozusagen mit ein bisschen Spenden, mit ein bisschen Unterstützung von Hackern. Und zumindest von meiner Seite ist das volle Vertrauen da. Ich würde jetzt gerne mal sehen, was passiert, wenn man Refugee Emancipation, die entsprechenden Mittel zur Verfügung stellt, um das mal in groß auszurollen. Weil, dass sie es können, haben sie halt schon bewiesen. Schon lange.
Also quasi nach Freilacht im Auto, lassen sie sich mal mit Geld bewerfen, gucken, was dann passiert.
Nein, das sind schon ganz konkrete Bedarfe, was immer eben auch sagt. Das wäre halt schön, das ist eben auch in großer Selbstausbeutung natürlich passiert, da eben Tier und da einfach auch Aufwandsentschädigungen zahlen zu können. Da redet man nicht pro Person, sicherlich nicht über hohe Summen, aber ja, das läppert sich halt alles ganz schön zusammen. Und Reisen, ich weiß nicht, wann habt ihr euch das letzte Mal eine Umweltkarte gekauft? Oder eine Berlin-Brandenburg-Umweltkarte, ein Jahr lang? Das kostet schon ein bisschen was.
Jetzt habt ihr gesagt, ihr habt es irgendwie zu zweit versucht, hat nicht ganz geklappt. Wer kommt jetzt noch dazu?
Ja, wir haben dann einen Plan gemacht eigentlich und sind erstmal mit dem Thema hausieren gegangen. Ich hab dann auf der Hey10 einen Vortrag dazu gehalten, dass ich vorhätte, zum Campin, was ja anstand, das Chaos Communication Camp, diese Spendenkampagne mit Monique und Freifunk zusammenzumachen. Das gleiche habe ich auf dem hedonistischen Weltkongress getan, beim CCC in Hamburg. Beim Netzpolitischen Abend haben wir uns mit Annabie Seddi und Fiona noch mal hingestellt und das Projekt erklärt. Und eigentlich kam so jedes Mal, wenn man darüber geredet hat, davon erzählt hat, immer noch mal ein, zwei Leute dazu. Es wird so eine Kerntruppe zum Schluss von 18, 19 Leuten waren, mit ganz unterschiedlichen Hintergründen, größtenteils schon aus dem CCC und Freifunkumfeld, was auch zum Schluss ja dazu geführt hat, dass es, nachdem wir uns irgendwann gesagt haben, so richtig Einzelpersonen sind wir jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr, weil wir haben hier gerade die volle Kraft von Freifunk und dem Förderverein und dem CCC am Rande zusammen. Dann war es halt ein kurzer Schritt, unsere Vorstände jeweils zu fragen, machen wir das als diese Organisation? Und die waren natürlich toll, wie sie sind, auch gleich Feuer und Flamme und haben uns unterstützt.
Ich hab mich selbst überzeugt.
Genau, Monique hat sich selbst überzeugt. Ich bin offiziell den Weg über unsere Vorstände gegangen und hab auch gleich mal bei den Sprechern angefragt, wobei da kam eigentlich gar kein richtiges Ja, da kam nur ein Machen, wie kann ich helfen? Und ja, war sehr beeindruckend und sehr schön zu sehen. Und so kam diese bunte Truppe jetzt zusammen und inzwischen eben dann offiziell unter dem Dach des Chaos Computer Clubs, des Fördervereins Freien Netzwerke und von Freifunk.
Jetzt ist es immer die eine Sache sozusagen, so eine Kampagne loszutreten, dann das Geld einzusammeln. Da ist es meistens so, dass alle Energie sich darauf zuspitzt. Und wenn es dann geklappt hat, dann ist die Luft raus. Gibt es schon so einen Plan für danach, was dann passiert, falls es klappen sollte? Also ich meine, wo man wahrscheinlich ausgehen kann, allein aus dem eigenen Umfeld?
Das Gute ist, wir dürfen ja umfallen und die Luft darf erstmal kurz raus sein, weil Refugee Emancipation bekommt ja das Geld und nicht wir. Wir sind wirklich nur Unterstützer. Das ist uns auch immer wichtig, das ganz doll zu trennen. Und wir sind nicht Refugee Emancipation, wir sind die Unterstützer. Und machen diese Kampagne zugunsten von Refugee Emancipation. Trotz alledem wollen wir nicht umfallen, sondern mehrere Leute haben schon angekündigt, dass sie auch über diese Kampagne hinaus weiter Refugee Emancipation unterstützen möchten, weiter mit ihnen arbeiten möchten.
Es gibt tatsächlich schon konkretere Pläne, dann auch für eine zweite Phase, denn um nochmal das Thema Hardware sammeln besser aufzurollen, das ist halt eine logistische Aufgabe. Die Heime sind in Brandenburg, da kann ich jetzt den Berliner nicht sagen, ja fahrt mal dahin und liefert das mal direkt dort ab. Das ist eine kleine logistische Herausforderung, die vielleicht durch Sammelstellen irgendwie zu lösen geht und zu organisieren geht. Und natürlich geht es dann auch weiter in der dritten Phase eben diese Computer Kurse zu unterstützen. Da haben sich auch schon Gruppen gefunden, die gesagt haben, Mensch, Geld ist ja das eine, aber da kann man doch auch ganz viel mit Zeit machen und so. Und dann sag ich, na klar kann man das, super. Genau und dann wird es dann in der zweiten, dritten Phase dann eben auch Workshops geben von den Freifunkern, die dann auch Flüchtlinge an der Stelle ermächtigen, selbst auch diese Infrastruktur zu warten oder aufzustellen, sich selbst zu helfen. Das soll immer das Ziel sein, Empowerment, also Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe.
Falls man sich das alles gehört und denkt, okay, das klingt ja alles ganz gut, aber wo Internetadresse, irgendwas?
support.refugeesemancipation.com Wie, das Schreibmuster selber rausfinden?
Vielleicht schreibt es ja auch jemand im Internet auf, der mitgehört hat. Es gibt ja da so Leute, die sich zur Sendung immer hinsetzen und alles feinsäublich mitschreiben unter Show Notes.
Und ich denke, wenn man dem CCC oder Freifunk oder dem Förderverein in den üblichen sozialen Medien selbst Facebook folgt, dann wird man das die nächsten Tage auch noch öfter mal mitbekommen.
Ganz wichtig ist vielleicht noch zu erwähnen, dass man sich zurzeit auf dieser Webseite für ein Newsletter registrieren kann und der große Start der Spendenkampagne spitzt sich also zu. Am 1. Oktober wird das lanciert und ab da können dann alle fleißig spenden auf diese Kampagne.
So, so. Wir sind sehr gespannt, was daraus wird. Ist dann der Werbeblock hiermit beendet? Gut, wir haben nachher noch so ein Thema, was es für Probleme mit Deutschland gibt, wenn man da Internet hinbringen will, also mit den Strukturen. Ich würde aber gerne nochmal vorher, weil wir gerade in dem Modus sind, nochmal sagen, es gibt ja auch noch wahrscheinlich andere Projekte, die sich mit dem Thema Digitales und Flüchtlinge beschäftigen. Zum Beispiel soll es einen Refugee Hackathon geben. Wer weiß von euch da genaueres?
Dazu kann ich etwas sagen. Und zwar soll am 24. bis 26. Oktober in Berlin der Refugees Hackathon stattfinden. Ziel ist es, hier haben sich ja unheimlich viele Gruppen gebildet. Also von Web-Plattformen über Facebook organisieren sich Helfer und Flüchtlinge, über Apps. Es gibt da diverse Apps, teilweise nur mit leicht verschobenem Fokus. Und ein bisschen ist es so, es läuft noch recht unkoordiniert. Jeder findet so ein bisschen das Rad neu, ganz viele gute Ideen. Und das Ziel dieses Hackathons ist es halt, die Leute zusammenzubringen, zu schauen, wo sind wir schon ganz nah beieinander. Auf der anderen Seite, was fehlt noch, sich da kennenzulernen und besser zu vernetzen, sich auch gegenseitig Input zu geben und am Ende natürlich dann auch am Wochenende da weitere Features zu schrauben und das Ganze zu hacken. Unter refugeehackathon.de kann man sich die Infos alle holen. Da sieht man auch schon eine Liste der zurzeit aktiven Gruppen dort. Aber da sind noch, also wer noch was weiß, wer da noch fehlt, dann auf jeden Fall dahin schicken.
Die Jugend ist auch schon am Start. Halt!
Ich wollte nur von wegen refugeehackathon.de. Was ich gelesen habe, ist, dass sie da mittlerweile, das ist ja in Berlin, sollte man vielleicht auch mal dazu sagen, in Berlin der hackathon, das sich mittlerweile also in Deutschlandweit irgendwie so auch abzeichnet, dass andere Leute auch was dazu machen. Also falls ihr nicht aus Berlin kommt, vielleicht ist in eurer Gegend da auch irgendwie was am Start. So, die Jugend?
Die Jugend ist auch am Start. Jugendhack wird als einen großen Track beim diesjährigen Jugendhack in Berlin Refugees haben und sich auch dort mit dem Thema befassen, gucken, was kann man da programmiertechnisch sozusagen machen. Das Ganze findet in Berlin vom 16. bis 18. Oktober statt. Ich hab gehört, es gibt noch ein paar letzte freie Plätze.
Für Hackerinnen vor allem.
Prima, die werden bevorzugt. Ansonsten mal neben Internet und weil wir vorhin ja auch sagten, es gibt auch durchaus andere Sachen in Berlin, wo es noch dran mangelt. Und das gilt dann eigentlich für alle Bundesländer, denke ich. Eigentlich hat jedes Bundesland ein Flüchtlingsrat, wenn nicht sogar Städte teilweise. Und der Flüchtlingsrat Berlin, den man mit Google ganz leicht findet, hat eine wunderbare Linksammlung zu so ziemlich allen lokalen Initiativen, wo man sich beteiligen kann. Da kann man wirklich, muss man noch nicht mal seinen Stadtteil zuverlassen in der Regel, weil vor der eigenen Haustür gibt es schon eine Gruppe, die sich kümmert. Und alle freuen sich über Leute, die helfen im Moment, weil es wird überall nach Unterstützung gesucht. Ich hab leider immer wieder jetzt auch Leute erlebt, die seit zwei Monaten kaum ihrem eigenen Job nachgehen, weil sie sich da voll dieser Sache widmen. Und je mehr Leute mitmachen, je mehr Schultern das Ganze tragen, umso leichter wird es für alle.
Okay, dann gibt es also genug Gelegenheit, um auch zu helfen. Wir wollen jetzt noch mal zurückkommen zu dem, womit wir auch angefangen haben, nämlich Internet in Flüchtlingsunterkünfte bringen. Und es wäre ja zu einfach, Probleme, die es dabei gibt. Welche sind das? Also ich meine jetzt abgesehen davon, dass man einen Internetanschluss braucht und technische Geräte dieses Internet sozusagen unter bis zu 2000 Leuten verteilen, gibt es anscheinend noch institutionelle Probleme oder formale Probleme oder was auch immer?
Also es fängt meistens mit dem Internetanschluss selber an, dass man den gar nicht hat. Das wäre ja zu einfach, wenn man irgendwie lokal einen VDSL-Anschluss bestellen könnte. Also viele dieser Unterkünfte sind far out. Da kann man dann froh sein, wenn man da 16 MBit ADSL hinkriegt. Und dann wohnen da aber viele Leute. Also es fängt damit an, dass man überhaupt irgendeine Art von Bandbreite herbekommt und die zur Verfügung stellen kann. Damit fängt es schon mal an.
Aber ich meine, das ist ja ein Problem, das kennen alle Brandenbogen. Gibt es da irgendwie einen Lösungsansatz für? Weil das ist halt in Deutschland so eine Art Naturgewalt. Wir haben halt einfach nicht überall Internet.
Das ist natürlich das eine. Klar, da kann man dann versuchen, mit Richtfunksstrecken irgendwas hinzubringen. Aber es gibt auch noch andere Probleme. Solche Unterkünfte sind manchmal auch einfach gegen den Willen der Betreiber errichtet worden. Also gerade hier in Berlin wurden quasi Sporthallen vom Deutschen Sportbund beschlagnahmt. Also nicht durch den Sportbund, aber vom Sportbund. Und die Bereitschaft, da jetzt irgendwie die Schränke aufzumachen und zu sagen, hier könnt ihr mal was anschließen, die ist da relativ gering. Weil die Leute sehen, die nehmen uns jetzt hier was weg.
Beziehungsweise, ja genau, dann kommt eben dieses Argument, was wir anfänglich schon mal entkräftet haben. Das ist doch gar nicht so entscheidend. Also gibt es nicht Wichtigeres so als das. Das geht dann aber auch weiter. Diese Betreiber-Organisationen sind ja sehr, sehr unterschiedlich. Einige sind sowieso schon aus Hilfsorganisationen, wie die Diakonie oder die AWO oder so. Aber es gibt auch private Betreiber, wo man damit ganz oder quasi Wohnungsbaugesellschaften eigentlich auch, die eine ganz andere Verwaltungsstruktur haben, mit der man sich dann rumplagen muss, wenn man da nun hinkommt und sagt, wir würden hier gerne helfen und unterstützen. Des Weiteren ist sicherlich technisches Unwissen ein Problem. Und last not least ist die Störerhaftung. Unsere alte Bekannte im Freifunkkontext, eins der größten Hindernisse. Es wirkt sich aus wie eine Kontaktsperre für die Flüchtlinge, weil die Betreiber eben sagen, wir möchten hier nicht in dieser Haftung sein.
Also Leute, die jetzt sozusagen ganz, ganz, ganz super aufmerksam das Chaosradio hören, die wissen möglicherweise, worum es geht. Alle anderen möchte ich auch bis nach den Nachrichten vertrösten und sozusagen das so schon mal andeuten. Es gibt eine juristisch-gesetzliche, ja ein Ding, was es verhindern kann, dass man dieses, was man eigentlich total, also eigentlich total gut. Hey, wir machen Internet für euch. Und dann gibt es sowas wie, ja, aber vielleicht bist du dann dran, wenn jemand was Böses tut. Und dann sagen viele Leute so, ha, nee, dann wollen wir das doch lieber nicht. Ich fasse es genau aus, das kennen wir gleich. Jetzt gibt es noch einen Musikwunsch, der mitgebracht wurde. Ja, bitte.
Ich wollte noch anmerken, die Anna Biselli von netzpolitik.org hat doch einen sehr schönen Artikel drüber geschrieben.
Ja, aber darüber sprechen wir doch gleich.
Ah, ich war jetzt nicht bei Störerhaftung, aber gut.
Worüber jetzt? Jetzt bin ich total durcheinander. Worüber denn? Hat sie über Slime einen Artikel geschrieben? Auch nicht. Gut, dann hören wir jetzt erst Slime und Goldene Turme und danach gibt's Nachrichten und danach klären wir den ganzen Rest.
Na, da geben wir doch mal unseren Senf dazu.
Dezember. Fritz Nachrichten mit Emily Ulbricht.
Die Bundesländer sollen vom Bund mehr Geld zur Bewältigung der Flüchtlingskrise erhalten. Die Regierung will sich monatlich mit 670 Euro pro Flüchtling an den Kosten beteiligen, sagte Bundeskanzlerin Merkel am Abend nach dem Treffen mit dem Ministerpräsidenten im Kanzleramt. Außerdem sollen 500 Millionen Euro für den sozialen Wohnungsbau und weitere 350 Millionen für die Betreuung unbegleiteter minderjähriger Flüchtlinge bereitgestellt werden. Ungarn schottet sich in der Flüchtlingskrise weiter ab. Armee und Polizei bauen derzeit Zäune an den Grenzen zu Slowenien, Kroatien und Rumänien. Das berichtete die staatliche ungarische Nachrichtenagentur MIT. Außerdem hat die ungarische Regierung angekündigt, die Ausgaben für den Bau von Grenzzeugen zu verdoppeln. Die Übergänge zu Serbien sind bereits abgeriegelt. In Saudi-Arabien hat sich eines der größten Unglücke der vergangenen Jahre während der islamischen Pilgerfahrt Hatsch ereignet. Bei einer Massenpanik in der Nähe von Mekka sind mehr als 700 Menschen ums Leben gekommen. Weitere 800 Menschen wurden verletzt. Der saudische König Saiman versprach eine schnelle Aufklärung der Unglücksursache. Außerdem wolle er die bisherigen Sicherheitsvorkehrungen während der Pilgerfahrt prüfen lassen. Mehrere Zeitungen berichten, dass Porsche-Chef Müller neuer Vorstandsvorsitzender beim VW-Konzern wird. Außerdem sollen weitere Manager ihre Posten räumen. VW-Chef Winterkorn war gestern zurückgetreten. Hintergrund ist, dass VW bei den Abgaswerten von Dieselautos getrickst hat. Heute bestätigte der Autokonzern, dass auch Fahrzeuge in Europa betroffen sind. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, die liegen in Berlin-Marzahn bei 11 Grad, in Reinickendorf sind es 14 Grad, in Forsten 10 Grad, in Zieser 11 und in Brandenburg an der Havel und Eberswalde jeweils 12 Grad. In der Nacht wird es locker bewölkt, bleibt aber meistens trocken. Erst morgens kann es etwas regnen bei Tiefstwerten bis zu 7 Grad. Morgen müsst ihr dann mit ein paar Meerwolken und teilweise auch Regen in Berlin und Brandenburg rechnen. Die Temperaturen sind ähnlich wie heute, 16 bis 19 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin, Neukölln, die Flughafenstraße ist zwischen Fontanestraße und Hermannstraße nach einem Unfall gesperrt und der Tiergattentunnel ist ebenfalls gesperrt bis 5 Uhr früh. Grund sind Wartungsarbeiten. Nach Brandenburg auf der A9 leibt sich Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Niemäck und Brück gab es einen Unfall auf der linken Spur. Die Unfallstelle ist noch nicht gesichert. Hier also bitte vorsichtig fahren. Da wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr diesen Sound mögt oder diesen Sound Dann hört doch mal Urban Tunes. Den Fritz Soundgarden mit Claudia Kameed. Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de.
Die letzte halbe Stunde im Chaosradio in Blue Moon ist angebrochen. Wir sprechen heute über Flüchtlinge und Hackerhilfe zur Selbsthilfe und zu Gast sind. Monique Meisel von den Freifunkern. Hallo und guten Abend. Ima Tchenko von Refugee Emancipation. Hallo. Lasse vom Chaos Computer Club. Und Elektra vom Chaos Computer Club. Und wir haben schon 90 Minuten hinter uns. Und die alle noch mal zusammenzufassen, würde den Rahmen der Verbleibenden seine Zeit sprengen. Deswegen nur ganz kurz, es ist wichtig, dass Flüchtlinge Internet haben. Auf wie das passieren kann, haben wir so kurz geklärt. Es gibt verschiedene Ansätze und wir wollen den einen jetzt noch mal vertiefen. Das ist nämlich der, dass man einfach in die Flüchtlingsunterkünfte geht und da Internet hinwirft. Wie man das dann genau benutzt, haben wir im Rahmen der Sendung schon erklärt. Aber es gibt da Probleme. Also es gibt nicht nur das technische Problem, dass man irgendwie die Technik hinschaffen muss und dass man irgendwie alles organisieren muss, sondern es gibt, wie soll man das sagen, übergeordnete Probleme, die bürokratischer, formaler oder juristischer Natur sein könnte. Und da ist ein Problem, das man haben kann, die Störerhaftung. Frau Meilde.
Also die Störerhaftung ist erst mal kein Gesetz, sondern es ist eigentlich lediglich eine Rechtsunsicherheit. Das kam zustande durch einen BGH-Uteil, was mal gefällt wurde in Bezug auf offenes WLAN, was sozusagen sagte, dass man für das, was dritte in einem ungesicherten WLAN tun oder ungesichertem Internetzugang tun könnte, verantwortlich gemacht werden könnte, sprich also eben auch haftet.
Da muss ich reingrätschen an der Stelle. Störerhaftung ist ein juristisches Konzept im Zivilrecht. Das geht dabei nicht nur ums Internet. Wenn eine Sache, die dir gehört, von jemand anderem benutzt wird, etwas zu tun, was mich stört, dann kannst du da unter bestimmten Bedingungen dafür in Haftung genommen werden. Und es ist tatsächlich so ausgelegt worden in den vergangenen Jahren. Also wir sehen, es ist auf dem Rückzug, aber dass Menschen dafür verantwortlich gemacht wurden, dass andere Leute ihren Internetzugang benutzt haben und sich zum Beispiel irgendwas von Madonna runtergeladen und hochgeladen haben über eines der Filesharing-Protokolle. Oder irgendwas anderes Banales.
Und um das nochmal zu konkretisieren, ursprünglich kommt das aus sowas wie du musst ein AKW sichern. Daher kommt das, da macht das auch Sinn. Gegen den Zugriff Dritter unter anderem.
Oder dein Gartenteich. Dein Gartenteich, da fällt ein Kind rein. Weil du den nicht gesichert hast, dann kann man dich damit belangen.
Genau, und dann wurde das eben von findigen Anwälten auf dieses WLAN eben auch angewandt. Und das WLAN oder das Internet wird dort als Gefahrenzone hingestellt. Was natürlich total lächerlich ist, denn uns einbewusst, dass das lediglich ein Kommunikationsmedium ist.
Genau, und du hast von Problemen gesprochen.
Wie haben wir eine Lösung dafür? Um das konkret mal deutlich zu machen, ich stelle mich jetzt als ehrenamtlicher Helfer und sage, ich richte euch einen Internetanschluss ein und damit es alles schnell geht, mache ich das einfach auf meinen Namen und dann surfen da, was war es im Teilfall, 2000 Leute über diesen Internetanschluss. Und wenn da einer Unsinn baut, was möglicherweise passieren kann, wenn 2000 Leute auf einem Platz sind, dann bist du als Anschlussinhaber möglicherweise in der juristischen Haftung drin. Und dann überlegt man sich das vielleicht irgendwie dreimal oder viermal, ob man das wirklich machen will, also ob man garantieren will, dass ganz viele Leute irgendwie alle keinen Unsinn brauchen. Wie ist die Lösung dafür, um sozusagen dem zu entgehen?
Gibt es mehrere Lösungen dafür. Wir haben quasi dieses Problem mit der Störerhaftung nur in Deutschland, was auch ein Grund dafür ist, dass Deutschland im internationalen Vergleich sehr weit hinterherhinkt, irgendwie was öffentliche Internetzugänge anbelangt. Da haben wir uns selber ein Eigentor geschossen und leider schießen wir immer weiter solche Eigentore. Und das wird auch immer so weitergehen, wenn wir nicht irgendwie aufstehen und dagegen was machen.
Ja, genau. Und die Lösungen sehen vielfältig aus. Wie gesagt, das ist eine Rechtsunsicherheit. Da muss das Recht eben ausgelegt werden. Das heißt, wir haben einmal den juristischen Weg bestritten, in zwei Beispielfällen haben wir dann die vermeintlichen, ja, gegen, also theoretisch steht man ja erstmal dann selber sozusagen, wenn man so, also die Konsequenzen kriegt eine Abmahnung, ja. Dann hab ich erstmal Angst und denke, oh Gott, oh Gott, was wir gemacht haben, ist immer gesagt, nein, wir zahlen nicht, wir unterlassen nicht bei so einer Abmahnung für Filesharing beispielsweise. Und dann ging es eben weiter, dass einfach mal gar nichts passiert ist. Und weil immer nie was passiert ist und komischerweise die Leute nur Angst gemacht wurde, aber am Ende niemand verklagt wurde von den Freifunkern, haben wir gesagt, Moment mal, dann drehen wir jetzt den Spieß um, Verteidigung nach vorne und haben Feststellungsklagen angestrengt, die wir im ersten Fall haben die... Aha, okay, eine Feststellungsklage bedeutet in dem Fall, ich möchte feststellen lassen, dass was du mir vorwürfst, du mir nicht vorwerfen darfst. Ist eine sogenannte negative Feststellungsklage. Ich lasse also negativ feststellen, um es mal ganz ausführlich zu machen. Da ist also Folgendes passiert, dass eine dafür sehr berühmte Kanzlei die Ansprüche für ihre Mandanten hat fallen lassen und auch in allen anderen Fällen gegen Freifunker, die da anhängig waren. Und im zweiten Fall haben wir tatsächlich am Landgericht Berlin einen gewonnen. Ein positives Urteil, was allerdings in dem Fall weniger auf die Störerhaftung konkret eingegangen ist, sondern hier war die erste Verteidigungslinie unseres Klägers zu sagen, ich zweifle an, dass die IP-Adressermittlung korrekt war. Das heißt, wir finden dann immer raus, wem gehört dieser Anschluss, zu der diese IP gehört und so weiter. Und wir wissen halt, dass sie in ungefähr 30 Prozent der Fälle inkorrekt ist. Und tatsächlich haben auch die Richter das so gesehen, dass sie gesagt haben, das ist hier gar nicht hinreichend dargelegt, dieses Verfahren der IP-Adressermittlung. Und somit haben wir gewonnen. Und Punkt. Eine Möglichkeit.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, aber wenn das... Ich wollte gerade sagen, eine sehr aufwändige. Das heißt, jetzt im konkreten Fall, wir wollen jetzt jetzt in 50-Sonderkünften, will man sich da wahrscheinlich nicht drauf verlassen.
Genau, weil ja auch, wir wollen ja auch, dass Menschen, die sich jetzt nicht so auskennen und vielleicht noch ein bisschen Angst haben, trotzdem Freifunk machen, haben wir schon vor längerer Zeit mit den sogenannten Freedom-Fighter-Boxes gezeigt, dass man mittels sogenannten VPN-Tunneln den Internet-Traffic umleiten kann. Und der wird umgeleitet entweder ins Ausland, wo es keine Störerhaftung gibt, oder zuletzt in letzter Zeit eigentlich auch zu deutschen Providern, die eben unter das sogenannte Provider-Privileg fallen, was dazu führt, dass man nicht in der Haftung ist, sonst hätte ja die Telekom auch ständig Probleme mit ihren Hotspots.
Und sozusagen dann, also in so einer Flüsschensunterkunft stellt ihr einfach so ein Ding hin und dann ist das sozusagen gegessen?
Genau, in dem Freifunk. Wir flächen ja die Router mit einer alternativen Firmware und in dieser Firmware trägt man dann diesen VPN-Tunnel ein, es stellt noch ein, wie viel Bandbreite man im Zweifel teilen möchte. Und genau, und dann hat man da im Prinzip schon den Schutz.
Wobei man jetzt sagen muss, das ist die Freifunk-Lösung. Refugee-Emancipation hat das anders gemacht.
Wir müssen kurz das Mikrofon wechseln.
Wir haben zu wenig Mikrofone für diese vielen Gäste. Ja, wir haben das anders gemacht mit dieser Internet-Räume. Also wir geben nicht nur Internet, aber wir haben dann diese DSL in diese Internet-Cafés. Und dann haben die Flüchtlinge dann Internetzugang mit dieser DSL-Anschlüsse.
Die Anschlüsse laufen auf Refugee-Emancipation. Also sie halten sozusagen ihren Kopf für die anderen Flüchtlinge hin, sprechen ihnen das Vertrauen aus, zu sagen, ok, ihr dürft alle über unseren Anschluss surfen. Und wir jetzt eben drüber geredet haben, was da theoretisch schiefgehen kann. Wie viele Fälle hattet ihr, wo es deswegen Ärger gab?
Also ich kenne einen Fall, wo wir illegal downloaden, also einen Brief bekommen haben. Also vor 14 Jahren kenne ich nur einen Fall. Ich weiß nicht, ob es noch mehr Fälle gibt. Also wir haben dann allgemein einen Vertrag mit der Heimbetreiber. Das heißt, wir haben in Anschluss die Hardways. Und was alles in diese Räume passiert ist, trägt Refugees-Emancipation die Verantwortung. Dann haben die Heimbetreiber gar nicht. Und von unserer Erfahrung haben wir selten Probleme mit solchen Fällen gehabt.
Habt ihr andere Probleme oder mit Dingen zu kämpfen, wo man denkt, okay, damit habe ich jetzt aber gar nicht gerechnet?
Allgemein begegnen wir sehr oft diese allgemeine Angst von den Heimbetreibern. Also wenn sie von einem selbst organisierten Flüchtlingsprojekt hören, dann haben sie diese Angst, wenn Flüchtlinge sich dann organisieren und über Internet, vielleicht könnte sie politisch werden. Und dann allgemein, sie wollen keine zweite Stimme haben. Der Heimbetreiber oder die Heimleiter sagt, wie es dort läuft, und wollen selten keine andere Meinung haben.
Ich verstehe das richtig. Die Heimbetreiber haben davor Angst, dass die Leute, für die sie das Heim betreiben, sich über das Internet so organisieren, dass sie sozusagen ein Gewicht bekommen.
Also dass die Flüchtlinge, also die Heimleiter, sie haben Angst, dass die Flüchtlinge sie organisieren können und dann politisch werden. Also dass sie ihre Meinung sagen können, wie wir dann leben, die Zustände sind nicht in Ordnung und so weiter. Dass sie sich dann besser auskennen. Also sie haben das Problem, also begegnen wir sehr oft diese allgemeinen Angst.
Aber wie äußert sich das? Ich kann mir ja kaum vorstellen, dass ein Heimleiter oder ein Heimbetreiber öffentlich sagt, ich will nicht, dass ihr euch organisiert.
Sie sagen das nicht, da sie Angst haben. Aber wir wissen das. Sie sagen, sie haben immer diese Ausrede, wir haben keine Räume. Wir haben andere Prioritäten. Und wer bezahlt das? Wir haben Angst für illegal Downloads und so weiter. Wenn wir dann sagen, alles was dort passiert, tragen wir die Verantwortung, dann sagen wir, ach nee, dann haben wir keine Räume. Wenn wir Räume hätten, aber wir sagen immer, Internet ist kein Luxus oder diese Räume, diese Internet-Cafés sind kein Luxus, es ist eine Notwendigkeit für die Flüchtlinge.
Also Anna Biselli von netzpolitik.org hat auch Refugee Emancipation kennengelernt im Zuge des letzten Jahres und hat sich dann mal ganz allgemein mit diesem Thema bundesweit befasst. Und genau die Dinge, die Refugee Emancipation im Kleinen zu hören bekommen hat, hat sie dann eigentlich bundesweit zu hören gekriegt. Das sind immer die gleichen Sachen. Erstmal, ja, die haben doch alle Smartphones. Dass sie darüber vielleicht keinen Datenvertrag haben, das haben wir schon drüber geredet. Die können ja öffentliche Zugänge nutzen. Da ist ein McDonalds in 5 Kilometer Entfernung. Da darf man eine halbe Stunde umsonst surfen. Das reicht doch. Und dann eben als dritter Punkt, den wir jetzt am ausführlichsten schon behandelt haben, genau diese rechtlichen Bedenken. Die surfen doch alle auf Al-Qaeda-Seiten und dann sind wir schuld. Kein Witz, also wirklich, das wird sehr, sehr gerne. IS ist jetzt gerade aktuell, früher war es Al-Qaeda. Davor wird es irgendeine andere Sau, die sie gerade durchs Dorf jagen gewesen sein, die dann schuld ist und alle Flüchtlinge machen ja nichts anderes. Dass sie gerade genau vor diesen Leuten flüchten, wird dann gern vergessen.
Wir haben genau diese gleichen Erfahrungen auch gemacht, mit dieser Verzögerungstaktik, wie eben auch Refugees Emancipation. Wenn wir mit diesen Betreibern reden, dann heißt es, der Internetanschluss ist zu schmalbandig, dann sagen wir gut, dann versorgen wir von außen. Dann sagen die, ja, aber wie ist denn mit der Haftung das? Dann sagen wir, dafür haben wir eine Lösung. Machen sie sich keine Sorgen, wir stehen in der Haftung im Zweifel. Und so weiter und so weiter. Es ist wirklich immer das Gleiche. Das ist wirklich traurig.
Der eigentliche Skandal ist, dass du es mit den einzelnen Haiben klären musst. Als wir dann geguckt haben, wie ist denn die gesetzliche Regelung und Anna sich gekümmert hat und wir haben damals viel geredet, stellte sich halt raus, es gibt einfach gar keine gesetzliche Regelung. Erst heißt es, es ist Ländersache. Die Länder sagen dann, je nachdem, wie das Land drauf ist, ja, das ist aber Sache der Gemeinde oder Kommune. Die Gemeinde sagt, es ist Sache des Heims. Und so wird sich der Schwarze Peter dann schön zugeschoben. Und genau für Freifunk ist es dann zum Beispiel auch ein Problem, mal zu einer generellen Lösung für ein ganzes Bundesland zu kommen, weil du auf einmal mit jeder Heimleitung einzeln reden musst.
Also ich meine, meine persönliche Einschätzung ist, dass hinter solchen Vorbehalten stecken häufig Ausreden. Und ich meine, es ist einfach nicht zu leugnen. Legen wir doch die Fakten klar auf den Tisch. Es gibt in Deutschland, so wie in vielen anderen Staaten auch oder wahrscheinlich überall auf der Welt, Alltagsrassismus. Den gibt es einfach. Es gibt ein Wir-Gefühl. Und Menschen, die anders sind, denen begegnet man mit Xenophobie. Die sind irgendwie anders, die wollen irgendwas von uns, die sind irgendwie komisch. Die wollen uns irgendwas wegnehmen. Ich meine, wir reden doch hier vor dem Hintergrund der ganzen politischen Diskussionen, die wir alle schon mitbekommen haben. Wir sehen das doch. Ich kann wirklich nur jedem empfehlen, mal in der Wikipedia den Alltagsrassismus nachzuschlagen. Und dass Leute dann halt an ihre Grenzen, ihrer Toleranz kommen, die immer so gerne zitiert werden und dann irgendwelche Dinge vorschützen, ist halt einfach auch ein gesellschaftliches Problem, was wir haben. Und das können wir allein mit Technik nicht erschlagen.
Oder zumindest nur mit äußerst viel Aufwand, der gar nicht nötig wäre, wenn man diese technischen Fixes da eben nicht bräuchte.
Also finde ich das nicht nur eine spannende Diskussion, die man nochmal führen könnte, wenn ich 15 Stunden vor Sender Schluss wäre. Ob das wirklich sozusagen der einzige Grund ist, weil ich mir tatsächlich, also ich habe manchmal den Verdacht, dass so, also gerade wenn so ich bin der Betreiber einer öffentlichen Einrichtung, dass es dann auch das hätt ich manchmal einfach ums Geld geht oder um die Angst vor juristischem Ärger.
Warum ist im Moment, wo wir jetzt diese Krise auch hier in Deutschland hatten, warum ist nicht das THW, das Rote Kreuz nach vorne gesprungen und hat gesagt, ja wir helfen, offiziell habe ich da noch gar nichts zugehört. Ich habe an verschiedenen Stellen mal nachgefragt. Es will keiner das in seinem Budget haben. Die sind doch selber alle schon landunter. Das ist ja nicht mehr böse, aber die wissen einfach auch, wenn wir jetzt die ersten sind, die uns aus der Deckung wagen und da was machen, ja dann müssen wir uns komplett drum kümmern und mehr Geld kriegen sie nicht. Also es hat dann noch immer, es hat vielschichtige Gründe und Geld ist dann auch bei solchen Sachen oft ein Problem. Wobei wir ja eben in Nachrichten gehört haben, dass da jetzt vielleicht sogar was passiert, aber erstmal abwarten.
Eine Frage treibt mich noch ein bisschen um, es geht ja sozusagen auch immer um die Internetanschlüsse. Wir haben jetzt irgendwie so relativ große Telekom-Konzernen in Deutschland, was das derzeitige Medienumfeld auch angeht. Also nicht mal aus altruistischen Gründen. Das machen wir jetzt einfach so, jetzt hinzugehen und zu sagen, hier wir bewerfen euch mit Internet und zwar kostenlos wäre doch ein totaler Imagegewinn. Man könnte natürlich auch auf die Gegend kommen, so große Firmen haben vielleicht gesellschaftliche Verantwortung. Warum passiert da denn nichts? Also das frage ich mir jetzt gerade wirklich.
Ich meine, es hat eine Presseerklärung der Deutschen Telekom AG gegeben, dass man jetzt den Flüchtlingen großzügig kostenlose Internetanschlüsse bereitstellt. Aber hier in Berlin ist nach meinem Wissensstand nichts davon angekommen. Also bitte korrigiert mich, wenn ihr das anders wisst.
Nein, ganz und gar nicht. Es gab Nachfragen dann auch seitens der Freifunker. Und da hieß es dann, man möge bitte die kommunalen Einkaufsstrukturen nutzen. Und das ist ja bekanntermaßen auch eher ein langwieriger Prozess. Und der dann auch zu den langwierigen Prozessen eines so großen Unternehmens passt.
Ich möchte jetzt keine Lanze für die Telekom brechen. Ich hab da auch keine Ahnung, was da jetzt genau wie passiert ist. Aber zum Schluss haben sie dann, auch wenn es lobenswert wäre und schön ist, vielleicht wollen die das ja wirklich gerade machen, aber sie haben dann auch wieder genau die gleichen Probleme, die wir gerade beschrieben haben. Die müssen auch mit jedem Heim einzeln reden. Das Problem ist so hochkomplex, dass du eben nicht mal eben was ausrollen kannst, solange nicht alle wirklich mal an einem Strang ziehen.
Naja, da muss ich jetzt wieder Wasser in den Wein kippen. Und zwar ganz, ganz heftig. Die Betreiber von Heim kommen teilweise jetzt zu uns, Mittwochs zu Freifunk und fragen, wie kann ich denn das bei mir machen? Und da wird dann auch darüber gesprochen, über ihre Erfahrungen. Da gab es diese Ankündigung und dann haben sie sich durchgefragt. Und sie wussten erst mal gar nicht, wer ist denn der Ansprechpartner bei der Telekom? Bei wem spreche ich denn da jetzt vor? Und dann irgendwann gab es von irgendjemanden eine E-Mail. Und dann kam die Antwort zurück, ihr könnt das nicht selber beantragen, das muss das Laggé so machen. Das habe ich jetzt in einem Fall gehört. Das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich, das läuft jetzt alles so informell. Na irgendwie, es gab mal eine Presseerklärung. Jemand bei der Telekom oder vielleicht mehrere Leute bei der Telekom haben gedacht, ja das ist eine tolle Sache, das machen wir. Aber letztendlich bleibt es dann eben klein klein und in der Organisation der Verantwortung und dem Kompetenzgerangel vermutlich stecken. Und in der jetzigen Situation zum Beispiel dann zu sagen, ja geht doch zur Laggé so, die muss das beantragen. Die sind völlig überlastet. Die sind ja auch keine Experten für solche Internetgeschichten. Also einfach so eine informelle Hilfe, die jetzt einfach Leute in die Hand nehmen und sagen, ja wir bringen ein paar Router mit und wir machen hier eine Funkstrecke. Sowas geht ganz schnell und geht halt auf dem informellen Weg. Aber sobald eben solche Organisationsstrukturen mit reinkommen, dann werden die Sachen halt wirklich träger. Also ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel an den Hurricane Katrina, der New Orleans getroffen hat, wo die Leute hinterher gesagt haben, also die eigentliche Katastrophe war, als die FEMA, die Katastrophenschutzorganisation, da das Handelnsheft in die Hand bekommen hat, da war das nämlich so, da gab es auch, das heißt da nicht Freifunk, sondern freie Netzwerkaktivisten sind hingefahren, haben sich Rad geholt. Ich hab dann per E-Mail geschrieben, Leute, wenn da irgendwie umgestürzte LKWs sind, nehmt die Batterien raus, wenn die noch gut sind, könnt ihr eure Route anschließen und könnt ihr irgendwie behelfsmäßig im Katastrophenfall Netzwerk aufbauen. Und die haben das gemacht. Und die wurden dann irgendwann von der FEMA daran gehindert, dieses System am Laufen zu halten. Also sie sind rein, haben Katastrophenschutz gemacht, haben Infrastruktur aufgebaut und wurden dann von der FEMA daran gehindert, das Gebiet wieder zu betreten.
Na gut, hoffen wir, dass es nicht so weit kommt hier.
Das war uns zum Beispiel in unserer Kampagne auch immer wichtig zu sagen. Wir wollen generell gerne, dass jeder uns unterstützt, von Kirche, über wen auch immer. Aber eben nicht, damit sie jetzt shiny sind und sich darstellen können, sondern sie sollen wirklich helfen. Also die Telekom hätte ja auch einfach mal direkt...
Oder andere große Kommunikation...
Oder andere große Unternehmen einfach mal direkt was machen und später drüber reden. Man hat manchmal das Gefühl, die geben alle erstmal eine Presseerklärung raus. Und warten dann mal ab, was passiert, anstatt erstmal Fakten zu schaffen.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt also sagen, bevor wir... Bevor wir jetzt noch ins große Firmenbashing kommen...
Nein, nein, Nis, das soll es echt nicht sein.
Wir machen jetzt sozusagen die Abschlussrunde, dann darf jeder noch einmal. Aber was ich darin gerne nochmal hätte, ist, dass ihr nochmal sagt, wenn ich jetzt konkret mich daran beteiligen will an diesem Ding, was soll ich machen, wo soll ich hingehen? Elektra-Fingern?
Ja, geht hin zu den Unterkünften und guckt euch die Bedingungen an. Gibt es da schon was? Wenn ihr selber Hilfe haben wollt, wie ihr das aufbauen könnt, dann kommt, wenn ihr jetzt hier in Berlin seid, zu uns in die Seabase am Mittwoch und lasst euch beraten. Und wenn es geht, könnt ihr schon mal prüfen, ob ihr irgendwo da in der Nähe, wenn es nicht selber in der Unterkunft selber geht, einen Anschluss kriegen könnt. Vielleicht gibt es ja freundliche Nachbarn, die, wenn man da einen Freifunkrouter hinstellt, der die Sache mit der Störerhaftung löst, bereit sind, ihren Internetanschluss erstmal zu teilen, sodass erstmal da etwas hinkommt.
Ja, ähm, zu Schluss werden wir sagen, also die Emanzipation und Empowerment von Flüchtlingen ist sehr wichtig, da sie selber dann sich äusen können, was sie lernen oder welche Weg sie in Deutschland gehen wollen. Und ja, also für diese Kampagne wollen wir natürlich Freifunk und Chaos Computer Club Berlin uns hässlich bedanken. Und danke alle, die uns gehört haben. Und danke schonmal für die Unterstützung.
Alles klar, Monique?
Ja, genau, ich schließe mich da im Prinzip Elektra an, wollte nur noch hinzufügen. Wenn ihr nicht in Berlin wohnt, dann schaut mal unter community.freifunk.net Da findet ihr die über 200 deutschlandweiten Freifunkgruppen. Sucht euch die raus, die bei euch in der Nähe ist, kontaktiert die, die beißen nicht, die helfen gern. Und dann geht's los.
Ja, ich würde gerne noch mal eine Lanze brechen, dass man eben die, was wir auch im Titel haben, Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe, dass man Dinge macht, mit den Flüchtlingen redet und nicht immer nur über sie. Und alle noch mal auffordern, sich unserer Kampagne anzuschließen. Wir sind noch offen für Unterstützer, sie bekannt zu machen, sie in den sozialen Netzwerken zu teilen, damit wir dann Refugee Emancipation auch unterstützen können.
Ab 1.10.
Gut, hätten wir auch das geklärt. Traditionell noch zum Schluss der Sendung, wenn hier Chaosradio ist, gibt es immer die nächsten wichtigen Termine im Chaos-Umfeld. Was wird uns da preisgeboten in der nächsten Zeit?
Ja, am kommenden Montag, dem 28.09. haben wir ein Datengarten-Spezial. Ausnahmsweise mal nicht im Chaos Computer Club Berlin, sondern in der Seabase. Da wird Eveline uns etwas erzählen. Der Titel ist From Secret Manoeuvres to Undercover Research. Sehr spannend, ab 20 Uhr. Und dann wird es wie im Vorjahr, zwischen dem 3. und 4. Oktober, das Vintage Computing Festival von der Afra wiedergeben. Das war letztes Jahr sehr beliebt. Alle, die nicht da waren, haben sich sehr geärgert.
Die werden Teilnehmer der Sendung angeschaut.
Auch dieses Jahr wird es abends wieder eine Chiptune-Party geben, ab 21 Uhr. Der Eintritt zum Festival ist kostenlos. Das lohnt sich für alt und jung. Da haben einen Haufen Leute viel Spaß gehabt. Und dann geht es auch schon gleich weiter, am zweiten Dienstag des Monats mit dem regulären Datengarten. Da wird es diesmal um WLAN-Sicherheit gehen und wie man WPA2 umgehen kann.
Da gibt es also ein spannendes Programm. Ich wünsche dir viel Spaß. Vielen Dank Elektra, Lasse, Ima und Monique für's Mitmachen und bei der Sendung dabei sein. Ich verabschiede mich an dieser Stelle und übergebe dann an Floheil eine Nightflight, der euch wahrscheinlich, wie ich ihn kenne, mit elektrisch verstärkter Gitarrenmusik bewerfen wird. Und mir bleibt nur noch zu sagen, mein Name ist Markus Richter. Lasst euch nicht überwachen, verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups und macht doch gerne bei der Aktion Arschloch mit.